in this video I'll be continuing with
the segment I've been doing on where the
Avengers are currently at in the MCU
today's video will be about Ironman but
before we get started please be sure to
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date on Avengers infinity war so we last
left off with Tony Stark and Captain
America Civil War and spider-man
homecoming both are very important
events for the MC used Tony Stark and
Iron Man because of the mentality that
he is facing right now the biggest thing
that happened in Civil War is obviously
the division between the Avengers and
more importantly the division between
Iron Man and Captain America
Tony relied on Captain and you can tell
he was seriously hurt by Captain America
tearing the Avengers apart along with
his friendship with Tony but at the end
of the movie Tony receives a
heartwarming letter from Captain and we
can tell that eventually everything is
going to be okay because Captain and
Tony are pals and always will be then we
have spider-man homecoming the biggest
thing that happens here is Tony becomes
a father figure to Peter Parker aka
spider-man another huge thing is that he
gets engaged at the end of the movie to
Pepper Potts
these aren't impacting because with Tony
getting engaged and him getting a feel
of what it's like to be a father it's
making him want to settle down and give
up the life of fighting supervillains so
it's most likely that the Avengers
infinity War part 1 & 2 movies will be
the last we see in the MCU of this
particular Iron Man whether that is due
to him sacrificing himself for someone
in the movie and dying or is due to him
calling it quits and stepping down to
start a family unfortunately these are
only things we can find out by waiting
for the movie to come out and it's
probable that some Avengers will die in
infinity War part 1 so maybe we'll find
out at the end of April the biggest
thing that everyone is talking about
right now is Tony Stark's new
bleeding-edge armor so first off wings
the armor has wings and arm blasters on
it which allows Iron Man to propel
himself into deep space most likely to
get himself to Titan which is a home
planet to Thanos and is where we see him
getting knocked out by Thanos and the
infinity war trailer secondly this is a
nanotech suit which means it's made out
of millions of nanomachines that can
shape into armor Street
clothes and even armor that isn't
attached to Tony Stark's body allowing
it to operate separately basically it
can shape into whatever Tony wants it to
shape into the armor is powered by the
arc t node or what is commonly known as
Tony's arc reactor Tony's new suit
actually isn't mechanical and doesn't
have any motors in it instead the nano
machines create a second layer of
essentially artificial muscle of Starks
body in which additional structures
assemble such as more armor or weapons
the armor is also self-healing the nano
machines replace and heal anything that
has lost or used
it's almost invulnerable due to this
ability this is the same type of
technology that Black Panther has and
how his suit is in his necklace allowing
it to be a suit or be regular clothes
and also being able to regenerate
another cool thing that we've seen and
some concept art is that one of Tony's
weapons appears to be an energy dagger
which Black Panther uses as well in the
comics the suit can create endless
amounts of weapons any weapon that Tony
imagines basically due to the nano
technology this is going to be really
cool to see on screen because Thanos is
pretty much the Avengers greatest enemy
so they're literally going to have to
pull out the big guns to defeat him
another awesome thing about the armor is
it fuses with Earl at one point in the
comics Odin lets Tony Stark have access
to the forges of Madhavi lair and he
creates a bunch of Erle weapons for
those of you who aren't familiar with
Earl
it's what Thor's hammer Mjolnir is made
out of and the dwarves of Nadav lair are
who made mule near Stark actually
infuses RL into his bleeding-edge armor
in the comics turning it into the iron
destroyer this means the suit can fuse
with elements I wonder what elements
might be good to fuse with for infinity
warp
I'm guessing that there will definitely
be some vibranium in the suit especially
if Tony gets the nanotechnology from
Shuri which we've seen clips of Cherie
speaking to Banner we know as besties
with Tony also what if Tony could infuse
his suit with an infinity stone this
logic actually makes sense if you think
about it none of the Avengers are strong
enough to face Thanos alone or even all
together as they are
but give one or some of them the power
of an infinity stone and they just may
stand a chance I'm curious to learn more
about which direction they go with his
suit in the movie what direction do you
think they'll go in Avengers infinity
war let me know in the comments below
what you'd like to see in the movie and
be sure to drop a like and again please
subscribe to my channel to stay up to
date with Avengers infinity war Marvel
and all things superhero thank you so
much for watching and have a great day